bonjour à tous nous allons voir
aujourd'hui comment fabriquer un masque
anti-projections fait maison sachez tout
d'abord que ces masques ne respectent
pas les normes de production
industrielle exigé pour les masques
médicaux il ne s'agit donc pas d'une
protection équivalente aux masques ffp2
de chirurgiens ou d'une barrière magique
antivirus mais ils vous permettront de
vous protéger vous et sur tous les
autres en limitant la progression du
virus pour le réaliser j'allais avoir
besoin d'un tissu d'un tee shirt ou
d'une écharpe d'une dimension de 50 cm
sur 50 et deux élastiques
si comme moi vous ne disposez que d'un
tissu en forme de rectangle placer les
côtés les plus longs verticalement le
masque recouvrira alors une plus grande
partie de votre visage
veillez bien à ce que le tissu vos mains
les élastiques et la surface que vous
utilisez soit parfaitement propre et
désinfecter plier tout d'abord votre
tissu à la moitié en eau
[Musique]
puis en bas replie ensuite le tissu d'un
quart enfilé deux élastiques sur les
côtés
[Musique]
e
puis repliez et emboîter les deux
épaisseurs de tissu le masque est déjà
prêt est reporté
[Musique]
veillez bien à ce que le masque recouvre
le nez et la bouche ajuster le bien pour
éviter les fuites
pas d'ouverture au niveau du menton du
nez il sur les côtés du visage
mettez le ayant levé le par les
élastiques ne devait jamais touché la
partie en contact avec le nez et la
bouche pouvez l'utiliser pendant trois
heures au maximum
il doit être laver en machine à 60
degrés pendant 30 minutes après chaque
utilisation
enfin le port du masque doit
impérativement s'accompagner des gestes
barrières laver régulièrement les mains
tousser ou éternuer dans votre groupe ou
dans un mouchoir
utilisez un mouchoir à usage unique
salué sans serrer la main et garder une
distance de sécurité d'au moins un mètre
avec les autres individus
[Musique]